let's go back to the phones and go to 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 that's the number you
call we'll go to the next caller from
the 9 7 3 area code caller from 9 7 3
tell us who you are where you're calling
from and what can I answer for you today
hi this is Jerry from new jersey great
what's on your mind I'm calling in
Webster the Bernie Sanders sigit Perry
bill yeah I was just wondering do you
believe that this issue is becoming like
a non-negotiable
and the Democrat Party as a whole okay
I'm sorry yeah hard time hearing you
lives take the question from the top and
let's turn let's turn Jay up as much as
we can and speak up please Jay do you
believe that Bernie Sanders single-payer
bill will become a non-negotiable for
the Democratic Party and they will
actually try to implement this or do you
believe that corporate Democrats are
just paying lip service to progressives
at a time where they know that this bill
can't actually get passed right there
so two thoughts on this number one is
the the question of whether the bill
will ultimately become law is a
different one from whether corporate
Democrats will be what gets in the way
right I mean the bill corporate
Democrats might not get in the way and
it might still not become law because
Democrats control nothing right now they
don't control the White House they don't
control the house they don't control the
Senate so as I mentioned earlier in the
week I do think that it's an easy thing
for Democrats in blue states to
co-sponsor because public opinion is as
in favor of this as they've been in the
modern political era of polling you have
no risk of actually having to figure out
the details before your next re-election
campaign in certainly in the house and
in the Senate it depends because
Republicans control everything right now
so I do believe that it's a sort of
gimme for a lot of Democrats and yet at
the same time I think it's really
important because and it sounds almost
naive but I do believe that it is
important that there is this on record
port unprecedented support from elected
officials on the Democratic side for
co-sponsoring such a bill more support
than we've ever seen before okay so
that's number one
and whether it's pandering or not or
what you know I think it's important no
matter what but it is a very easy
decision for a lot of people corporate
Democrats may well if it has a pay
chance to happen and it's not that's not
going to be before the midterms for sure
and probably not before 2020 corporate
Democrats might get in the way we talk
about many areas where Democrats and
Republicans are the same and we talked
about many areas where Democrats and
Republicans are very different both
Democrats and Republicans by and large
get a lot of money from the health
insurance industry this is a proposal
which would be really bad for the health
insurance industry so I think you're
thinking about the dynamics of money and
politics the exact right way yeah
corporate Democrats could get in the way
of this if it ever has an actual chance
of passing oh wait one more quick point
yeah um so but do you believe that if
they say they take back the House and
the Senate in say 2018 that the moment
the political momentum of this bill
could like make the whole party like as
a whole adopt this as I can on
negotiable issue or do you believe that
that the Democrats still will get away I
I've been advocating for a while Jay
that the Democratic Party officially
make this a part of their platform and
you know what that doesn't mean that
even if they say this is our platform
and it's non-negotiable that doesn't
guarantee that it's going to become law
if Democrats take power we've seen how
that works in the past we've seen a lot
of those types of statements backfire
under the Trump administration so I do
believe that Democrats should officially
make Medicare for all healthcare for all
single-payer part of their platform I
believe that they will not and I do
believe that the more moderate and
corporate influences in the Democratic
Party would be part of that Jay thank
you I appreciate the call I do have to
move on